Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and welcome to the three phases of line course so this course is going to really go through my book
Maybe in greater detail try to give you some more
The more reach the most recent information that we have on how to
Really helped you take care of yourself
especially in the third phase of line so
Little bit of background into myself. I had Lyme multiple times
and then
Figured out through the course of seed patients with Lyme
That there were really three phases that came up with that idea
I didn't know what does it years or so ago
So if you hear anybody else talk about three phases or the third phase of line
They got it from me not that I'm you know bragging about that
But I really realized that there is this third phase that people always talked about chronic Lyme
And oh, I have chronic Lyme and I can't get better
Well, I realized that there is this third phase of line beyond chronic Lyme where you really have an autoimmune disease
Because of the line pathogens, so when I say line pathogens when I talk about Lyme I'm not talking about just
Borrelia. I'm talking about
Any smathering of co-infections that could go along with with Borrelia
So understand that through this entire course if I'm talking about Lyme
I'm talking about Borrelia and or
The co-infections because there's just too many things that can be going on with Lyme disease
It's never just one bacteria
So this third phase of line that we're going to talk about
In this course in detail is that autoimmune phase and that is the more difficult one to treat and
And which causes so much grief for patients
Because they're every time they try to treat it. They're stimulating their immune system and causing more problems
So these this three phases is the phase one. I call the acute stage Lyme
That's the acute infection phase two is what would be called chronic Lyme
And then phase three is this autoimmune phase of Lyme a lot of people who say they have chronic Lyme
They've had it for multiple years. They really may be in phase three in an autoimmune state
So by definition phase one, it will go through these through the modules
So but in definition phase one the infection is still in the blood or the tissues
It has not yet entered into a cell that is the difference between phase one and phase two
It has the infection has not yet entered into the cell and I talk about the infection. We're talking about the pathogen
the Lyme and or its co-infections. So
These bacteria, these viruses that go along with Lyme disease that we classify as Lyme disease are
infectious agents their pathogens and they
Start off and are introduced into the tissue either by a tick by getting into the bloodstream circulate around the bloodstream and
Your immune system should be sparked to kill it. Now a lot of people get Lyme disease every single day
It never really gets sick because their immune system was able to kill the pathogen. That's what your immune system is supposed to do
so there's people that are getting Lyme maybe
Tens of thousands of people that are getting Lyme on a daily basis and their immune system is killing it and they never
They never even know what the word Lyme means are here about it because they never really got sick
But when our immune system isn't able to kill it it continues to reproduce
Replicate in the in the bloodstream typically in the tissues and
And if one of these
Pathogens gets inside the cell then that's what's called
Chronic Lyme. So that's how I define chronic Lyme is that the pathogen is entered into the cell
It's much more difficult to kill now because your immune system does not go intracellular
So your immune system you have macrophages T cells and
Other natural killer cells that kill pathogens. That's what your immune system does your immune system doesn't detox toxins like
Pesticides your immune system kills living organisms that are trying to invade your body either that you consume
Orally through your gut cavity or that you breathe in or that were injected in you via some sort of
tick or other
Vector board illness now those pathogens got in the tissues get in the blood supply should trigger an immune response and
Your immune system should kill it if they're fairly very lent to your immune system
Isn't able to kill it before it's replicated quite quickly and getting into other tissues and once it enters inside the cell so it crosses in through the cell membrane
Into a cell now it's kind of outside of the control of your immune system
If you can think of your immune system is like a bunch of police officers that are trying to kill the bad guys
Soon as that bacteria or virus goes inside the cell the police can't go in there
It's like a border. The police don't go in there. So your immune system is not getting in there
They have the ability to know replicate without any really
Consequences inside the cell and that's what is chronic Lyme
And so even if you do take
Antibiotic or specific nutritional, let's get a spark a better immune response
You're not going to kill the things that are inside the cell and then phase three auto immune
Lyme is defined as now one's immune system is making antibodies against one's own cells
So this might take you know from phase one
I just got bit by a tick to phase two literally could be days most of the time it's it's weeks or months
So you have a window of opportunity of treating with an antibiotic if it's a bacterial
Between phase one and phase two and that's what I did for my Lyme
I recognize it is Lyme because I got so
Deathly sick in phase one some people don't that's the problem they never get sick, but it really is
Still replicated in their body and your immune systems are not taking care of it. It's getting inside the cell quite quickly
And then that becomes a major problem long term now. I was able to recognize my Lyme disease quite quickly because I got so deathly sick
And I took an antibiotic and I killed it
Now, you know, just need to use antibiotics, but if you know you have face one live a bacterial infection
Usually the antibiotic is a wise thing
So if you're in phase one, I recommend antibiotics, but we're going to talk about that detail through these modules
That's a window between phase one and phase two. There's a window and then there's another window between phase two and phase three
So back to the window between phase one and phase two
I know I'm talking fast. We'll go over this in detail, but the window between phase one and phase two
Could be there could be days could be weeks could be months and then the window between phase two and phase three
Could be weeks could be months could be years
So a person could be in phase two chronic life for years and then are still able to manage it and
Correct it through immune stimulants through herbal immune stimulants through supplemental or immune stimulant
And they can manage it and treat it that way
If you move if that window closes and you move to phase three meeting your bodies making antibodies against self tissue
Completely different treatment program. You have to change everything and we'll go over this in detail. So auto immune
Phase three line is your body is making antibodies to self tissue
You are making antibodies to your old cells
Which ones? Well could be any so really it's going to be where that bacteria or that
Co-infection
You know is more populated
That's the most common thing. So where you have more population of that
That co-infection let's say it's your thyroid gland then you could end up with Hashimoto's
Let's say it's other tissues you could and your gut you could end up with a colitis and also to colitis and a crone's disease
So it just depends you're gonna have an autoimmune disease that's named after the tissue that you're creating antibodies against
Many times most people the greatest percentage of people with autoimmune disease don't have a named disease
They just have the symptoms of autoimmune disease, but they haven't yet
gone through the diagnostic process to actually get a named disease
We don't want a named disease. We do at need a label. We just need to treat the autoimmune issue
And that's what this course is going to be about is to help you guide you through that
Oh a lot of information
That's why I wanted to make a course on of it to help you walk through this
And um to help you really be able to
Start taking care of yourself and looking at yourself a different way that you're not necessarily
You know having these symptoms for no reason
No, are you having
These symptoms that um nobody no doctors but able to figure out discover doesn't mean that you're crazy
So this is really going to be a self-help course for you to take this information and to self-apply it
Um, and I need to stress that the purpose of this course is the self-help course
You're not going to be able to call the clinic and have a meeting with me and us take you on as a patient
Um, it that's probably not going to be able to happen. We are too busy with cancer patients in our office
um
And so that's the big reason why I created this course is to help take care of line patients
without having to take care of line patients and
I just wish I could clone myself and be able to help more people. I just can't do that. So this course is to be able to
Maybe clone myself
To you and that you can take care of yourself
So I'm going to try to give you as much information so that you can self-care in this not that you don't want to use a
The functional practitioner that lives near you and and can work through these things together
But the problem that we hear from people is that I can't find anybody that knows what to do for me. I can't find any
Truly lime literate doctors or doctors that are literate and autoimmune diseases
And things like that that really know how to take care of me
Well
You could take this information as you're going to learn of this course and maybe
self-apply a lot of it and then get help from a functional doctor that's near you
That's our our goal in this. We're going to give you a lot of guidance through different ideas
So the guidance through ideas is going to be
Is going to be a work on progress. So we're going to be adding new stuff all the time to this
because
There's new things that come up and new information that come up
We're going to give you some ideas because there's no perfect way to
Know here all you got to do with phase three live is do
One two three four five six and you're going to be better. It just does not work that way
There's too many
Side factors that can be going on that that that make your problem unique
And we're going to talk about a lot of those side factors and how to deal with those
There's going to be a lot of education on self-care in this course
So that you can take that information and be able to work through it. So you have to be able to
You have to be able to study you really do or if you're a person
It's like oh my gosh the EMF sort of my computer. I can't watch this. I can't do this
Then you're going to have to get somebody to help you
And do the study for you and help you apply this information
Because wisdom is really the application of knowledge, right?
So I'm going to try to give you as much knowledge as possible from the wisdom that God gave me
And then for you to be able to apply that knowledge to yourself
That's the key and like I said, we're going to have new information in this
We're going to have new modules that are going to come up right now
We're going to have seven modules. We're going to have and multiple new modules
That that are going to be able to help you as I learned more
Information as I put more information together for you as we talk about those other pieces
That are unique to you and others in in
Your struggle with an autoimmune
Lime and chronic live. We're going to be adding modules. So understand this is a living course
That's what I call our courses our living courses because I feel like
One of my roles is that is that as God gives me information. God gives me knowledge
My
Application of that knowledge
AKA wisdom is to then convey it to other people
So that they can better help themselves one of the major reasons why I'm doing these courses
I believe we're moving into an era that self-help
Healthcare is going to be necessary
We are moving into an era where
Doctors in the medical profession are basically
Completely governed through the nutraceutical
Institutions that are out there and
If we really want to help ourselves we need to and I mean all of us need to learn more about our conditions our bodies
And how to take care of it ourselves
This is going to be crucial in the days ahead
So take this course keep coming back to it a lot of you
I know are going to be really educated already
But if you've had life for a long long time and you could teach this course
so I apologize
for
Baby you know rehashing through things
For people that are in that category
But know that I'll be constantly adding new information as I gain new information for you to be able to make choices
That are going to be best for you
As I always know that I'll be praying for you
I pray that and I ask that you guys pray for us as well
What we do is not favorable to the medical community
And they're constantly attacking us
So continue to pray for our protection and can take
Pray for our ability to continue to try to help people
All right, blessings to everyone. I hope you enjoy the course
And I just hope that it's a blessing to you
Bye-bye